bevor wir an die frontlinie gehen müssen
wir unsere schusssicheren westen
anziehen sind verabredet mit einer
einheit der territorialverteidigung die
die ortschaften vor den russen schützen
sollen
wir fahren los und im falle eines
beschusses was bei der momentanen lage
nicht passieren dürfte halten wir das
fahrzeug an alle steigen aus und legen
sich auf den boden wir suchen nicht nach
einem sicheren unterschlupf sondern
legen uns einfach alles klar
wir folgen dem kommandanten der sich
skipper nennt alle hier haben sie
kampfnamen skipper ist 42 und eigentlich
anwalt er hat sich wie alle hier in
seiner einheit freiwillig gemeldet mehr
als ihre kalaschnikows haben sie nicht
an ausrüstung
in einem kleinen wald streifen zwischen
den äckern haben sie schützen gräben
ausgehoben
immer wieder werden sie von den russen
angegriffen
dann bleibt ihnen nur in den gräben
schutz zu suchen
sie stehen in dieser richtung ja sie
schießen aus großer entfernung die
geschütze stehen 20 kilometer von hier
und schießen in diese richtung
[Musik]
es ist ein ungleicher kampf das wissen
sie gerade ist hier alles ruhig das
getreide steht schon hoch aber ernten
wird es wohl niemand die männer zeigen
uns die einschlagstelle einer granate
ganz in der nähe aber auch die geächtete
phosphormunition die alles verbrennt
setzten die russen ein sagen sie weil
die felder schon trocken sind und dann
schneller feuer fangen an ihrem sie
haben post vor bomben gegen uns
eingesetzt wir haben das helle
aufleuchten gesehen so führen sie den
grill die brutalität in diesem krieg
nimmt zu die soldaten zeigen uns videos
von granaten die neben ihrer stellung
eingeschlagen sind worüber sie nicht so
gerne sprechen auch bei ihnen gibt es
opfer zwölf tote 70 verletzte
dass sie alle hier ihr leben riskieren
schwer vorstellbar für deutsche die
jahrzehnte in frieden leben
sie neben in frieden sie bauen ihre
wirtschaft immer weiter aus wir sind in
einer anderen phase wir müssen den feind
besiegen und dann die demokratie
aufbauen
die krankenwagen hier transportieren
schon lange nicht mehr nur zivile
patienten auf dem weg zu einem front
krankenhaus irgendwo im donbass den ort
sollen wir nicht nennen aus angst vor
angriffen
das team ist immer in alarmbereitschaft
rund um die uhr werden schwer verletzte
soldaten angeliefert
gehirnerschütterungen
splitterverletzungen für den
anästhesisten andres i miev heißt dass
jeden tag ausnahmezustand
unser team leiter der großartig ist
kümmert sich um die triage
sortiert die patienten die hier
herkommen und definiert welcher fall
schwierig ist welcher zuerst behandelt
werden muss wer sofort weiter
transportiert werden
ein soldat mit einer schweren verletzung
muss versorgt werden
ein granatsplitter hat sein rechtes bein
unterhalb des knies zerfetzt andrä und
sein team stoppen die blutung es muss
schnell gehen nicht immer können sie
steril arbeiten der mann muss verlegt
werden später erfahren wir sein bein
konnte gerettet werden
für mich ist ein schlechter tag nicht
ihr die am schwierigsten ist
an dem es die meisten toten
es ist wahrscheinlich der tag an dem wir
verletzte kinder
das ist für mich psychologisch die
größte herausforderung
medikamente sagt andré gebe es genug
aber der wahnsinn das grauen des krieges
die angst um familie und heimat machen
vielen seiner patienten zu schaffen
ganz ehrlich es ist einfach noch nicht
genug zeit vergangen für die soldaten um
in dieser jüngsten phase des krieges
eine posttraumatische belastungsstörung
zu entwickeln
also seit februar aber viele von den
männern sind seit 2014 in der armee sie
hatten also schon psychologische
probleme und das manifestiert sich auch
im krankenhaus gibt es ständig luftalarm
ukrainische luftabwehr raketen fliegen
über das gebäude es ist eine ganz
normale nacht im kriegsgebiet
unterwegs halten uns andré und seine
freunde an es ist ein spiel an einem
echten checkpoint der chef ist ein
elfjähriger und hat eine plastik waffe
wir sind die 17 panzerbrigade auch in
unserer schule haben wir diese brigade
die soldaten der territorialverteidigung
neben uns mit in eines der dörfer als
die angriffe der russen besonders
schlimm waren hatten sie das dorf
evakuiert jetzt sind fast alle bewohner
wieder zurück die soldaten sind
entschlossen das gebiet zu halten
ihre einzige hoffnung waffen aus dem
westen
wir haben sie etwas zurückgedrängt und
zwei bis drei kilometer die erfolge sind
so gering weil wir ausschließlich
leichte schusswaffen haben
mit schweren waffen könnten wir nach
meiner einschätzung das ganze gebiet bis
zum meer befreit
die bodengewinne der russen die vielen
opfer auch bei ihnen und ihren kameraden
das bewegt sie alle und das gefühl dass
der westen zu langsam reagiert haben sie
westliche waffen schon bekommen
also 34 panzerfäuste sonst nur alles was
für den nahkampf nötig ist
mit einer reichweite von einem kilometer
aber die artillerie schießt sieben bis
zehn kilometer weit
damit meint er die russen
deshalb brauchen sie schwere waffen so
dringend das heißt dringend am liebsten
schon gestern
zu wenig zu spät trotzdem bleibt ihnen
nichts anderes übrig als weiter auf die
unterstützung des westens zu hoffen